hello and welcome to this episode of the
future verse brought to you by
intelligence squar and Whitey I'm Kamal
Ahmed white Tre was founded in 2017 to
give its clients the transparency
efficiency and meaning they need to
fully understand their financial lives
as they are and as they could be this is
the final episode in our latest midi
Series in which we've been digging into
what it means to be truly successful and
today we want to get practical what are
the tools and insights that we can use
to build happy and healthy lives to help
me out I'm joined by two leading experts
in this field from two different
disciplines a designer and an economist
a mechanic engineer by training Dave
Evans teaches the popular designing your
life courses at Stanford and is the
co-author of the New York Times
bestseller designing your life how to
build a well-lived joyful life Dr Grace
Lorden is an associate professor at the
London School of economics and the
author of think big take small steps and
build the future you want she's also the
inaugural director of the Behavioral
Science MSC at the lsse and has served
as an expert advisor to the UK
government sitting on their skills and
productivity board Grace and Dave
welcome to the
podcast delighted to be here thank you
for having me thanks for having me happy
to be here brilliant we're going to have
a lovely period of time together but
let's just go a little bit into
backgrounds for you both Grace could I
come to you first uh could you share for
us all a bit about your background and
how you arrived
in This brilliant position where your
expertise is now in advising people on
their own lives yes so I mean I I I
became quite interested in studying
productivity from the perspective of
firms so I spent a lot of time looking
at teams and what makes teams work
better together with respect to being
more productive and from that I used to
get invited to give talks in big
companies about productivity from the
perspective of the firm but also why we
had these gaps between men and women
when it came to paying promotions and
very often the type of things that I
would be describing that people could
change would be done at the team level
so you would need a manager who was who
was bought in or who would be done at
the firm level so the firm would have to
have kind of really big
changes and usually after the talk
somebody would come up to me and you
have to understand that when you give a
talk to a big organization the people
who show up there is a selection bias
they tend to be younger they tend to
have slightly more time and they tend to
have less power in the organizations and
people would come up to me and say you
know your talk was was was was
interesting interesting Behavioral
Science is interesting but actually
everything you pointed out was things
that's beyond my control what can I do
for me so I I took this really seriously
you know there was so many people kind
of said it to me over time and I thought
it would be really nice for me to do
some research on the area of how people
can Propel their own success and what
success means to them but also bring
together the large literature that was
already there in Behavioral Science so
that's what kind of brought me to
writing think big take small steps and
build the future that you want which I
hope helps people who are
stuck in the wrong career stagnated in
their career or in some other way want
to actually change what they're doing in
life get to where they want to go too
thanks so much grace Dave could I come
to you just a bit of your background now
we were joking slightly before we
started this recording I'm doing this
recording on a Macintosh and you have at
least a slight role in the birth of this
amazing product but just start there and
then take us through to how you ended up
in this amazing position you now find
yourself yeah it's it's it's a very
strange job to have talking to people
about designing their lives um no I
spent 35 years in Silicon Valley and
high-tech stuff which I fell into pretty
accidentally because I couldn't make a
living working on Advanced Energy
technology which is what my degrees were
in in
1976 and those degrees did not come with
a brochure that informed you oh by the
way this's thing we've just taught you
how to do nobody will do or care about
for the next 37 years um that was not in
the brochure so I had to reinvent myself
and I fell into it's a long silly story
I fell into Apple in the early days um
and was the world's first Mouse product
manager in 1979 before most of your
listeners were born um so that's where I
go back to actually the the leas a
computer which preceded Macintosh um so
go way back in Tech and then went off
and did lots of other things with people
building products but I was on that very
first Apple corporate culture committee
with Steve Jobs in 1980 uh the first
year I was at Apple we grew between from
800 to 5,000 people um so that's pretty
fast and um yeah about every bus loads
people arriving daily and there is sort
of this terrorized fear that oh my God I
mean all these people from you know
National semiconductor and H Packard are
arriving at Apple you know and and we're
going to suddenly be overtaken by these
other people who don't get it and how do
we sustain what makes apple apple while
all these otherly thinking people
suddenly arrive and so we formed a
corporate culture committee before there
was such a thing as corporate culture um
and what I noticed in that work was
everybody cared about their lives I mean
I was you know my late 20s 30s deeply
struggling with trying to figure out how
to do Dave authentically in the Work
World the kind of things that Grace was
mentioning and um everybody else was too
so that's been on my mind on the side
corporate culture how do we create not
just cool products but cool places to
work where people can be their real
selves in some kind of meaningful way as
well as you know get the job done and
that's that's a difficult Brew U that
turned into a an invitation to teach at
Cal Berkeley in in 1999 and then my
buddy Bill Bernett started this thing in
Stanford I said hey how don't we why
don't we hang out that was 2007 and then
you know we started teaching a class and
off you go then we wrote a book and
everybody bought it and then got to talk
to you so that's I I don't know how da
this is obviously the highlights of this
journey uh as well as speaking to Steve
Jobs you've now spoken to Kamal aled so
that's the two giants the book end of my
life Steve andal so um Dave tell me talk
to me about um what is life design uh
what what is it how does it work and
what are the principles okay well very
briefly that trying to do a semester in
a minute um so in the world of design by
the way there are largely two completely
different categories of design which I
describe as you know design thinking or
design Innovation and then there's craft
design the word design if you just use
it by itself most people rightly think
about CRA you know graphic design you
know ergonomic design you know Furniture
Design you know you know car the people
make cars look cool those are the
designers and that design has been
around since before G You Know da Vinci
uh and it's a wonderful field and it's
not what we teach at Stanford what we
teach at Stanford is uh formerly known
as hcd human centered design started in
1963 the oldest interdisciplinary
program at the University integrating
engineering art and psychology um and so
we've been teaching people and we
started out teaching people how to
innovate solutions to Wicked problems
that turn into appropriate new products
so product design is a methodology
not a not a craft skill uh David Kelly
renamed it design thinking about 15
years ago um and that sort of stuck so
it's a different way of thinking and
that way of thinking boils down
essentially to uh prototype iterations
or have a bunch of really cool ideas
then prototype Your Way Forward because
we know we don't know what we're doing
we're doing something we've never done
before we're inventing this place to go
no one's ever been before called the
future and so you can't analyze it you
can't think it you can't engineer it you
have to actually empirically try it so
it's a trial and error process very
compatible with Grace's approach to take
small steps one of our colleagues at in
the Design Group BJ fog who's a
behavioralist Grace you probably know
wrote a book called tiny habit so we're
all about set the bar low and clear it
which means prototype iteration so we
teach people how to apply these design
approaches to designing not a product
but their lives um and so you know we
can help people sort of sneak up on
their future by doing this empirical
process of
innovation Dave can you give me or help
our audience or listeners with a
practical example of that timely step
that I could think about in my life sure
let's say I'm I'm think first of all you
know we got asked once on one of these
live interviews can you summarize the
book in you know in a sentence say well
go that's kind of typical journalist
yeah but we came up with four sentences
but it's only two words and so the
posted version of the entire book is get
curious talk to people try stuff tell
your story um so if you do those four
things and understand how the inter
relate you're good to go you can skip
the 232 Pages or whatever it is um uh
and an example would be gosh you know
I'm in my career and I'm pretty I'm I'm
doing Finance I'm pretty bored I think I
want to do marketing and and I know what
I need to do I need to stop out I need
to get an MBA at night I need to go to
the lsse you know where Grace teaches
fact I've got one of my mentees who's
just flown to London and he can't find
housing he's at the lsse and he's making
himself crazy you know you know which is
a very very impactful thing to do it's
expensive it's long it's hard and then
you finish that master's degree and then
you you do job interviewing and then you
you get your first six months you go oh
I this is what marketing really is I
don't like this very much at all okay
that's a really good example of not
doing life design um it's the way a lot
of people would make a strategic
decision and have you committed and are
you all in um and it's a terrible
approach um and so we would say look you
know you if you were going to prototype
that you'd go you know have coffee with
a bunch of people who not only were
working in marketing but it made the
shift to marketing from some other field
and what they learned about what was
different and what was how did they how
did they handled their misperceptions
and how what were they surprised by and
then try to get some guy in marketing to
maybe maybe the company working in now
go find some reason why your Finance
function deserves to have an
intersection with the marketing people
and do a little ride along sit in on
their staff me go get some experience so
do this experiential thing we call that
life prototyping um in order to get as
Dan Gilbert would said from a research
point of view surrogation input not
simulation input simulation read a bunch
of stuff and think in your head what you
think it might be like that means you're
simulating reality which in very often
is a lousy way to make a decision as
opposed to go out and talk to real
people and have real experiences which
is surrogating reality and that actually
gives your discernment capacity in your
brain better information now just before
I come back to you Grace can you explain
to us Dave the difference between a
design problem
and and an engineering problem yes so
there's lots of ways to think if I just
compare engineering thinking with design
thing and I have two degrees in
engineering the design program is in the
engineering school but Engineers work on
tame problems that's a technical term
developed by urban planners at Berkeley
back in the 70s and a tame problem is
well- bounded it's understood there are
actual solutions to it and when you
solve a tame problem that solution is
repeatable and reliable you build a
bridge you know engineer builds a bridge
and understand strength and all that
stuff and if I move that bridge from
England to the middle of the Arizona
desert like we did many years ago um
it'll work fine it'll look stupid but
it'll look fine it'll work fine that's
an engineering problem where you solve
your way forward in a design problem is
are wicked problems a wicked problem is
I don't know what I'm looking for till I
find it once I find it I can't repeat it
because it's totally context sensitive
like your life there's not another Grace
so the grace solution doesn't work for
Kamal you know um and it keeps changing
in real time time so those are wicked
problems and you can't solve those with
equations because you don't have enough
information you have to iterate them
experientially and that's what design
can help you do it's really like improv
in theater and what life is an improv
skit it's a long running improv skit
we're doing improv training for people
in life design thank you uh Dave um
Grace explain to me in the same way as
people who some people who may not
understand and Behavioral Science how
does Behavioral Science which is a
really growing discipline uh someone I
was formerly the economics editor of uh
BBC and one thing there was behavioral
economics and this notion of Behavioral
Science how does that help us understand
human decision
making so I think you know a very easy
way to think about Behavioral Science is
just that it is the study of human
behavior and it's a really important
area of study because very often human
beings make PL hands to do particular
things and they'll declare boldly that
they're going to make a change in a
particular direction and they in fact
will fail at that and they will
repeatedly declare that they're going to
do something and they just don't show up
for themselves so that intent action Gap
is one big area of study within
Behavioral Science I think if you came
to the lsse one of the first things we
talk about with students is um o to
Danny canaman who won a Nobel Prize um
and his book thinking fast and slow I
couldn't recommend it more highly but
that there's two different thinking
Styles so one very very fast you're an
autopilot is habit driven the other is
very very slow and very very deliberate
and I think what's fascinating about
these two thinking Styles is that the
best evidence that we have suggests that
we spend about 80 to 95% of our waking
hours actually in this habit driven mode
so when you think about your career I
guess you want to think about two things
and when you think about success you
want to think about two things first how
do you define where you want to go and I
really like what Dave has just said this
the the idea of kind of trial and error
so there's a bunch of tasks that make
out jobs up in out in the world and you
go and start trying them and how will
you know what to try well you talk to
people who've already who've already
forged that path and then I get guess
the second thing is given that we know
people don't really regularly show up
for themselves how do we get them to do
this very very regularly and very very
routinely so how do we get them to take
this um these small steps and I think
Behavioral Science has a lot of insights
in that regard about how the biases that
are more likely to kind of circumvent
you from getting to where you want to go
and how you as an individual can
strategize to make sure that you
actually do show up for yourself and
don't end up you know sitting in front
of Netflix for an evening when you
planning on going out networking and
meeting some people about your new
career or doing other things that might
give you some joy in the moment but
don't really help your future self so
much and Grace again as I said to Dave
can you make this practical for us what
what would be some actual real life
examples of of of of how this this this
method really that Dave and you are both
putting forward for how to think about
the future of Our Lives particularly in
the workplace how practically that might
uh be
revealed so I think thinking about jobs
as bundles of tasks is a very effective
way to go forward so rather than
thinking of yourself I want to be a
lawyer I want to be a marketer I want to
be an accountant think about what are
the things that you enjoy doing that
absolutely give you flow in that
particular moment and I think until
you've nailed down the there these are
10 tasks that I absolutely love and I
really enjoy doing them and I want to
get a job that will allow me to do those
10 tasks as much as possible keeping
your options open is a really kind of
good way to um it's a really good way to
go forward and I couldn't agree with
Dave Moore if you're not 100% sure about
what your passion is going and doing a
degree that's very very costly and
that's going to give you debt given that
we kind of have democratized education
now and you can find skills online and
you can find lots of really excellent
public events to go to isn't A wise
choice so you know for example if you
realize that you enjoy coding if you
realize that you enjoy public speaking
if you realize that you enjoy kind of
creating events putting yourself in
situations where you're with people who
do that for a living but also how you
also get to practice and I think a
practical tip for um people who are
listening is that you should be doing
that at least 90 minutes a week so
really kind of saying there's a minimum
threshold that I'm going to show up for
my future self and it's 90 minutes a
week and the reason that it's I I I put
that as so low is that this is kind of
the minimum time that's being shown to
be effective in investing yourself that
leads to compounding effects but also
there's going to be listeners who will
say well I've caring responsibilities I
have to work to pay the mortgage I have
to do I have to do and they will always
be constraints to stand in your way but
everybody can carve up 90 minutes in the
week to show up for themselves to kind
of move them towards a different future
and I think if you're not doing that
right now it's really important that you
get
started Grace you said at the top of the
um this podcast that lots of people
people maybe don't feel empowered to
have this approach and don't have this
um uh they don't have the ability to
take this autonomy in their workplace
what what do you say to people who said
well yeah that's all very well but
actually I've got to apply for a certain
job and then I've just got to apply
myself to that job are there ways that
you can think about that if you are more
Junior in a team for example I mean I
think any thing that says that I have to
do something people should be
questioning it so there's always going
to be a subset of people out there who
say look this isn't for me I'm not
interested in Blue Sky Thinking I I'm I
there's there's one thing that I have to
do and and I'm going to get on with it
and maybe that isn't the audience for
for my book think big I think who I'm
trying to speak to are people who know
that they're sitting in the wrong job
who know that they're not going fast
enough who know that they haven't
necessarily they haven't necessarily
found their passion and for them
visualizing their future selves is is a
really good way to get motivated so I
think we are most of us and and most of
your listeners will be engaged in their
community in some way or engag with
their colleagues in some way that you
take care of other people so you pay it
forward you pay it backwards and you you
you really look out for other people M
much less of us actually look out for
our future selves in the same way and
give ourselves the same time so I like
to visualize my future S as kind of a
community of people and thinking about
you know when Grace is 40 years of age
is she going to be taken care of when
she's 50 when she's 60 when she's 70 and
what am I actually doing now that sets
them up for success and what am I doing
that sets my current self up for success
and again I think that can be a really
good motivator if you can bring and I'm
really excited about AI movements in
this where you can generate your future
selves because it makes everything much
easier but if you can visualize where
you want your future self to be and what
they'll actually be doing it's a really
great get good motivator to get you
going for that 90 minutes a week which
really is a very short amount of
time and Grace just before I come back
to to you Dave tell us about me plus
which is a first chapter uh of your book
just just widen that out for us and
explain what me plus
means so your me plus is the person who
you want to be if it all works out
usually when we think about the future
people put lots of different constraints
on it so I can't travel to get to where
I need to go there's too many things
that I have to do in in my life I'm I'm
just too constrained so I ask people to
do kind of this Blue Sky Thinking and
think what if it all worked out and
instead of Blue Sky Thinking as we've
already said with labels really in line
with what Dave has said um when you're
designing your life you're thinking
about what how are you actually going to
be spending your time what are the tasks
that you're going to be actually doing
and in doing that you create this vision
of of me plus who is your community of
future selves and just by simply
visualizing um in that way and imagining
who you'll be in five years again is a
good way to kind of remind yourself what
you're actually doing when you show up
for that 90 minutes um every week can I
jump in and just agree with Grace and
add on to that yes please okay so one
thing we find a lot is um particularly
with young people young early career
people particular if they feel like
they're stuck in a job and they're
overwhelmed by the tasks is I'm I'm
trying to F I'm trying to get it right
you know this isn't it it's got to be
over there you know I'm the wrong place
and and so I need to make this big move
you know in our second book designing
your new work life we talk about the
best person to get a better job from is
you don't resign redesign so it may well
be that you need to make a shift okay
that's fine but our recommendation is
start small and actually recognize that
in every job we're talking about making
my life better in the job I'm in now
there's the stuff there there are you
know musthaves nice haves get really
smart you know game the system
understand what it is the organization
needs from you understand why they need
it from you you know they they they
wanted to hire a midfielder you know and
you want to play goalie well that's
great but you know we need a midfielder
you know so get your Midfield done get
whatever your assignment is figured out
and then recognize there's lots of room
around the side where you can make
incremental changes what you call so
four strategies for modifying your job
level one is to just reinlist change
tell the story you're telling yourself a
different story a different narrative
that allows you to have a different
experience of meaning making and
satisfaction that's literally just
changing your story that can be
profoundly effective the second one my
favorite is remodeling I can make minor
changes I can hang up a new piece of
artwork you know I can move the
furniture around you know I can change
the way I do my reports I can you know
do one-on-one conversations with my team
members not necessarily a staff meeting
I can make minor structural changes that
correspond to how I work and really
satisfactory to me you know I can
relocate I can maybe jump departments or
what have you within an organization
that already trusts me or all the way up
to reinvent myself which might mean more
training and a and a more expensive
difficult shift but boy there are a
couple of pretty cheap easy to move and
two out out of four processes that don't
even require your boss's
approval by the way most organizations
don't mind getting more value for free
they're already paying you and if you
did something that was valuable to them
and interesting to you on top of your
current job yeah I'm saying work more
then your satisfaction goes way up one
thing we tell people a lot is don't
conflate a significant psychic dividend
with a small time change and Grace might
think about this from a Behavioral
Science point of view you can it's a Ur
Rising if I just had a little more
one-on-one interactivity it turns out
one-on-one interactivity really floats
my boat great so you come in 20 minutes
early two days a week and have coffee
with one of your team members and ask an
incredibly penetrating question like so
how's it going no how's it really going
and then you have this actual authentic
conversation twice a week for 20 minutes
you know and all that meant was that you
took one one train sooner those two days
a week and and you're experienc the
entire week can shift so give yourself a
chance to get the most out of the life
you're in you don't always have to make
a big change or cram a bunch of new
stuff in most people are leaving tons of
value on the table in the in the life
that's in front of them right now I love
that I I love the idea of job crafting
so you're in a role and let's try start
moving slowly slowly towards tasks that
I actually love while still doing some
of the things that I that that I that I
enjoy less and we really with most
people haven't the faintest idea what
they like or what they're actually good
at yeah they misinterpret themselves all
the time one of my favorite example
young man I know he's actually in the
book He's renamed his real name is
Morgan he was a civil engineer came out
of school went to work you know got into
a small Architecture Firm theoretically
a great situation a year into it he's
incredibly unhappy I meet him and he's
just about to shift over to becoming a
stock broker oh his father-in-law
happens to be a stock broker oh there's
a little inti okay um and because you
know apparently I don't like being a
civil engineer kind of go whoa whoa whoa
I don't think you know anything at all
about what you like and dislike you're
two years out of college um here's what
you got to do we call the good time
journal the Goodtime Journal is you just
log you do not make any changes you this
is very difficult to do by the way
objectively observe yourself without
modifying your behavior Grace may have
some comments on how to do that it's
very when you're self-managing you got
to know yourself step one in design is
empathy and the first person to be
empathetic for is yourself what am I
really like so you know Morgan tracks
you know what did I do today what did I
like where was my energy you talk about
this you know and then at the it turns
out guess what he loves civil
engineering he hates Administration he
hates client management he hates you
know being on te he actually hates being
on teams like please lock me in a
windowless room with a screen and a
quadril pad and a pencil and hard
problems oh I'm so happy you know so it
turns out so actually goes back to get a
PhD and work on really hard problems on
an in an analytic firm because that's
what he really wants to he's a super
engineer he's not a bad engineer he's a
super engineer just shouldn't have
anything to do with customers um so
learning who you really are step one and
then step two how could that what I
really like doing Express itself in my
current job in a way that is compatible
with my bosses and my colleagues rather
than incompatible you know which is an
easy mistake to make I'll start doing
the stuff I like that they never asked
for or they don't care about that's GNA
fail that happens all the time um so get
smart and get happier I think that
learning about yourself Dave as well it
mightn't even be binary so if you start
like writing down your mood yeah when
you're doing different activities you
might realize okay I like public
speaking and I like networking sometimes
but if I have too much of that my week
goes entirely off and you get so
learning you know the kind of mix of
activities that ultimately will make you
happy like your colleague Morgan means
that you can actually choose a job that
works best for you Dave one of the big
themes in your book is that there is no
one right you you this notion of I have
one thing I want to do or a singular
purpose passion just elaborate on that
it's probably our censal dysfunctional
belief we talk a lot about dysfunctional
beliefs that's a psychological term for
ideas that are popular and either at
least ungena of or in many cases just
flat out untrue um and so like I need to
find my pass so what is your passion
that's the driving qu we got to rep as
the anti-p passion guys now which is
unfair we love passion we just disl the
dysfunctional belief of it and so let's
just take that question what's your
passion okay that question believes
things the research shows eight out of
10 people answer that question gosh I
don't know Dave I haven't found mine yet
or I've got a bunch which one did you
want to hear about first now either of
those people who represent what's called
completely normal human beings um are
not directed do not have the directivity
of a singular passion and they think
something is wrong with them that
question believes number one everybody
has a passion number two it's singular
number three can be turned into a career
number four you'll ear you'll know it
early in life before you've even done it
and number five the world's going to let
you make a living doing it and guess
what all five of those are false not one
of those is true um so be very careful
which questions you decide to authorize
to judge your life all right and what's
your passion is allows you question to
judge your life our conviction is and
our observation both scientifically and
empirically is after and but our
anecdote piles like in the tens of
thousands now um
every one of us contains more aliveness
than one lifetime will permit you to
express I.E there's more than one of you
in there so there is no one right you we
argue there are many good
's um so you know so we we in fact I
just give a big talk to a larg
university on um why don't try to find
your purpose because that implies
there's
one do live
purposefully I mean like what are you
doing and why you want a really good
answer to that that's consistent with
who you are as a human being but like
that's it that's my single purpose that
Singularity that exclusivity idea um my
one snowflake version of life is an
incredibly attractive idea frankly it's
a reasonably arrogant one there is I am
so utterly unique there's only one thing
that the Universe wants from me and I
I've been put to do that one thing and
the whole world is organized around me
frankly it's it's a little egocentric um
like dude do that that you know um
there's 8 billion people here all we
really want from you is something
interesting that's alive making as
Joseph cample might say um and and it's
contributory and if you're on your way
toward that and you're growing as a
human being you're doing a great job so
lighten up relax a little bit you're
never going to get fulfilled fulfilled
means all of you is happening you're way
too big to have all of you
Happening Now Dave Dave Dave give me an
example where this has helped you you
and I'm going to come to to you as well
Grace I think this is really fascinating
this conversation but Dave give me an
example where some different use
appeared oh yeah and helped you make a
decision well I'm looking at one right
now so I mean a couple of months ago I
turned 70 I'm 70 freaking years old you
know um sadly I had I so I was you know
successfully but but rather unhappily
married for 24 years as a young man and
then very amicably got divor just had
dinner with my ex-wife um then was very
happily married for 20 years to a
wonderful woman that I buried three
years ago because she got cancer again
we agreed she wasn't going to do that
and she went off and did it and she died
on me and you know at the age of 70
which was sad but not tragic she had a
wonderful life you know and now have a
new chances are I'm going to die having
been married three times I never would
have thought that true when I was 20 so
I'm 70 years old I have 11 grandchildren
and I've done all this stuff I've had
five careers I've got some choices in
front of me so my next Milestone is
death death is my next big milestone and
so like what do I do so I could
be the education reformer you know run
over to lsse hang out with Grace I mean
run around the world do this education
reform thing we don't talk about this
enough with young people we should
change education back to adult formation
go for it Dave change the planet before
you die thing number one thing number
two I've got 11 grandkids my father
killed himself when I was nine I didn't
have a dad growing up I was a pretty
good dad I could be a world-class
grandfather if I just decided to invest
deeply in these 11 lives that is a
career ladies and gentlemen and by the
way they're pretty neat kids and they
all like me um or or you know I could go
off and just you know the heck with you
guys I I I I I gave my goods I've sold a
million books what do you want from me
I'm going to get my bearboat captain you
know certification go down to the
Caribbean and sale catamarans the hell
are you people um I'm done now you know
um now those are pretty different people
and those are legitimate choices I
actually can make can't do all three at
the same
time and Dave how is your system or how
could your system help you make good
choices given those amazing
opportunities you have ahead of you well
what first it starts
with all three of them are viable
expressions of who Dave is I could
literally do any one of those three
people and if I lived into them well in
including both the opportunities and
accepting the constraints we could
generate a happy person there but
they're happy very very different way so
actually have an exercise where you
write a better back to your present self
you assume five or 10 years from now you
lived that life you imagin become that
future person you know in
2033 and he writes a letter back to you
and says what that life was like and
then you listen to those guys and decide
which one of those people which one of
those memories would you like to
actually experience and it's not better
or worse there's not a right answer like
the real one shimmers and the other ones
fade away sometimes that occurs that's
great but if you're really lucky it's an
possibly hard decision and then you have
to accept it's not about having
everything it's about having worthwhile
things and as my mentor would say to me
at this point so Dave how's the coffee
is the coffee good we're having a great
moment so the first thing is to free you
to be in the present moment as a fully
Alive person that is as good as it gets
having it all is a complete myth
Grace I I'm just sitting here I think
Dave should do all three I think he
should he should say three years I'm
going to do three years with education
three years with the grandkids and then
I Mo to the beach they can visit me if
they want I'll have these amazing
relationships they're welcome okay
you're welcome anytime I think you can
do all three um it's similar Kamal it it
really is so I think that there isn't
kind of one passion that I've had in in
in my career that has kind of driven
what I'm doing and as I kind of go
through my career I would describe what
I do now as a portfolio career so I'm a
very traditional academic I do need to
do good quality research so that's
absolutely something that I do kind of
the core of my tasks but the things that
give me joy in the spirit of how how
Dave um how Dave spoke but them is often
the impact that comes from the research
so talking to policy makers talking to
firms about what it actually means for
them so that's another strand of work
that I've started doing um I've started
doing more public speaking I've you know
I'm I'm creating a podcast so kind of
creating this um portfolio of tasks that
go around my core career for me has been
incredibly valuable and unlike Dave
where he has kind of three big things to
choose from all of these are possible
with some kind of crafty time balancing
and I think for people who are listening
who do feel torn in a number of
directions maybe having a portfolio
career is something that you can you can
look into it doesn't need to be one
thing that you that you do to generate
income and also actually doing multiple
things can be something that brings joy
to people as well depending on their
personality and Grace let's talk about
the few of the um the the words the
descriptors that are used in Behavioral
Science which is pigan in effect
confirmation biased amission versus
action bias can you just take us through
some of that terminology and and how we
can how that can help us think more
cleverly about our
futures well I mean one thing that I say
to people who really have no idea where
they want to go is that they should get
themselves a diverse boardroom so they
should surround themselves with people
who are quite different for themselves
um and really try to leverage their
advice and the reason that I say that is
because of confirmation bias so as
individuals we tend to seek out people
who think exactly the same as ourselves
we definitely don't like being
challenged and I think actually as
Society has gone on that's happening
more and more you can just go onto
social media and see polarization and I
think when it comes to you as an
individual never mind resolving
society's problems but you as an
individual one of the best gifts you can
give to yourself is get the perspectives
of individuals who are very different to
what's actually going on in your life
and if you get people who are the right
people you know two things happen you
get the great advice so you kind of
overcome your confirmation bias but all
these other biases like availability
bias familiarity bias start being
challenged by this diverse Network and
what's even you know um even more
fantastic is very often they'll give you
opportunities that you would not
necessarily have had yourself and you've
mentioned the pigan effect which is one
of my favorite studies where these
researchers went into into a US school
you know back in the 60s and they
pointed out the high ability kids and
they left and they you know when they
went back your listeners mightn't be
surprised
that the high ability kids were the ones
who were driving the most until I tell
you that the high ability kids were just
randomly selected the researchers had no
clue as to who was high ability and who
was low ability and the reason we
explain that is about belief so if you
have people your diverse boardroom who
believe in you you'll start rising to
the occasion so if people are suffering
from kind of lower self-confidence
imposter syndrome all these things that
are stopping them getting going and they
can't self motivate just putting
yourself in front of people who are
diverse and critical I think that second
part is really important you you do you
don't want people who are going to hug
you and tell you you're right in every
situation you want people who will be
critical and kind of push you forward
that's going to give you the pigmon
effect which really is if you suffer
from self-belief one of the biggest
gifts you can give to yourself Dave I
love this terminology I think it really
helps people think Dave you've talked
about prototyping let's add that to the
nice big soup of terms that we're using
here
so yeah we talk prototyping really is
the cardiopulmonary system of design
thinking it's it's it's the essence of
what it's all about when you know you
don't know what we talk about wayfinding
versus navigation I'll give you another
couple of terms so uh nav navigation
technically means I know exactly where I
am I know where I'm going I have data
about the spaces in between I can create
an optimized path which would be a
straight line if at all possible and
that's what your GPS does and because
we're surrounded by technology all the
time we think we can navigate anything
mean we can solve it way finding is when
I kind of know where I am I definitely
don't know where I'm going and I have no
data about the space in between so now
what you do well you make one move and
you stop and you reflect you look around
and you get some feedback and you make
another move then you make another move
then you back up a little bit because
you you didn't make a mistake you just
did learn something you didn't know you
didn't know and then you take this very
circuitous apparent path and end up in
this other place now again for those
watching on video here's the critical
thing in wayfinding this path jumping
all over the place and circling around
then finally Landing that place you
didn't know you were going to until you
got there is the shortest distance
between those two
paths in Mortal time that totally
nonlinear path is the shortest possible
distance in an empirically Discovery
oriented process called wayfinding and
so when you wayfind prototyping is a
technique to go out and have
conversations and experiences that ask
an interesting question to give you some
feedback on the next step you're going
to make so an engineering prototype asks
the question did it work does this new
jet engine work well enough when you
throw a goose through it that we can put
it on a Plane full of people that asks
the question does it work right yet not
a design prototype a design prototype
kind of goes like Oh I wonder if i'
actually I sort of like running meetings
I wonder if I'd actually enjoy talking
to like 50 people at once doing this
public speaking thing can I go try a
prototype of that that's a feedback loop
on an experience I've never had before I
can't analyze that question I got to go
try try it and so prototyping is about
try something for the purpose of
learning something not oh I just took a
new job as a public speaker and I've got
everything betting on it that's that's a
way too big a risk so a prototype is a
lowrisk experience or conversation that
asks an interesting question about
something you'd like to learn more about
then you iterate those and then finally
go hey I think I'll actually take that
speaking ge now we've talked about
popular ideas that might be bad ideas
Now goal setting that's often used in
thinking about your future thinking
about the management of the futures of
other people Grace can I come to you
first is goal setting productive or
counterproductive so I'm in the middle
so there's people who really like goal
setting you should stick to your goal
you need to go for it and there's people
who say don't you should navigate your
way around I think setting a goal gets
you off the starting blocks but you
should be ready to change direction so
you know you you don't you might say I'm
driving to San Francisco and along the
way you decide to go a different a
different course and that's absolutely
fine and I think for people who suffer
from procrastination and who suffer
basically from being a little bit
stagnant saying that they're aiming for
something that's lofty that's blue sky
that's kind of you know something to aim
for is enough to get them having those
conversations with the people you know
Dave and I have been talking about where
they learn about the task that they do
they start trying out what those people
are doing and they say no that's not for
me but if I pivot slightly now I'm
moving towards something and then they
change the goal again so I like the idea
that people have at least a medium-term
goal that they're aiming for but it
needs to be something that can be
changed as they discover their own
preferences along the way now Dave are
you going to talk about goals setting
with a plural behind it or do you not
like the whole terminology of that it's
it's it's uh it's radioactive territory
and people have deep convictions about
almost religious convictions about
there's a there's an end of the coaching
world and we bump into the coaching
World a lot that's really into this
aspirational goal setting and huge
accountability Stu and frankly that
stuff makes me nuts um I think it mostly
is beating souls to death um so I I'm a
big advocate of what I call Stacked
objectives
plural um one of my older sisters is an
educator um often working with people
doing a second career pivot into
education and she she carefully reminds
them watch out for setting a life goal
the outcome of which is entirely in the
hands of people who are not you
your chance at satisfaction wants to be
something more in your own control uh
and so a stacked objective for me
example would be when Bill and I started
what became the life Design Lab you know
four or five Stacks number one like if
we're lucky we might actually help a
couple of kids at Stanford that's goal
number one goal number two if we do that
job well and a bunch of kids liked it
then maybe students will tell each other
and they start believing in student
culture we deserve help from the
University not only about how to learn
things but about how to figure out what
to do with what we learned maybe that
should be something students ask for and
if that goes well maybe the
administration would notice they're all
whining about that and then may the
Stanford University would say hey maybe
we ought to actually incorporate this
into the way we do student orientation
and student development and then if that
gets some traction maybe the educational
World kind of goes hey maybe we had to
come back to adult formation as part of
the the University's job not just educ
not just information maybe because they
used to do it 200 years ago they don't
do it anymore so can we come back to
adult formation is part of our job we
and we can do that in in a value
independent way we can do that in an
inclusive way without being prescriptive
there's a way to pull that off that'd be
great and then Society at large kind of
goes oh we've we've been misperceiving
what young adults are about for the last
150 years we need to think differently
about what it means to become a person
so I want to go all the way from couple
of kids at Stanford had a good time up
to I'm repositioning anthropological
perception of the existential purpose of
human beings on the planet forever ever
so you know give yourself a shot so I
have an aspiration out there but a
couple steps along the way so you're not
screwed if you don't hit hit the mark
there's a quite a few steps between
those two things Dave but thank you so
much for laying out ambition and also
small steps at the beginning now big
scary word big scary word
failure how Grace I'm going to come to
you first how do we think about failure
and Grace I'm just going to say we've
heard a lot of people saying failure
should be treated as a success success
it's part of your life's journey so I
get that big of it bit of it but I
imagine that you might have an even
cleverer take on what failure even
is I mean I think if if I if I had my
way I would ban the word failure when it
comes to thinking about career
progression and and you know people say
you should fail fast you should
experiment fast so try and learn as much
as you can and and that really is all
failure is you know when we think about
labeling things success versus failure
we imagine that there's this kind of
binary world where everything's within
our control and if we put in enough
effort we'll get to succeed and if we
don't we get to fail and that's not true
so rather than failing fast we should
experiment fast but I think equally when
we succeed we should be doing postmortem
and asking ourselves why did I succeed
in this situation did I just get lucky
or was it something specific that I
actually did that allowed me to realize
this success so you can double down on
that and I would do the same for
failures and I actively do that for
myself when things don't work out I I'll
say okay this didn't work out this time
was it down to me or was it just down to
some luck or some other factors outside
my control and if it was down to me it's
something that I can learn from and kind
of move on if it's down to luck I've
learned just myself off and move on and
I and I hope your listeners can as well
um I know that when we anticipate
failure even more than experiencing
failure itself it can hold people back
because there's some evidence in the
literature and and there's kind of more
people studying this at the moment that
the physical effects that you have when
you and anticipate and you you think
about failure are much larger than
actually going through the failure
itself because people are beautifully
are beautifully resilient so for me for
people listening I I wouldn't just
question what your attitude to failure
is I would also probe yourself if what's
keeping you stuck is anticipating
failure and never getting off those
starting blocks Now Dave similar
question failure good or bad word how do
we think about it it comes up a lot and
we're be large because in the design
World we're famous for saying you know
you want to attain failure immunity very
much that fail fast to succeed sooner
thing which is true but that's actually
couched very specifically in that
prototypes prototype's job is to learn
something so of course it's going to
failure you never wanted your prototype
to become the the outcome it was I'm
just going to go try to learn something
you know and if I break it that's fine
now we've that idea of failure immunity
has gotten so popular that I think we've
done people disservice so go do a bunch
of design prototypes and try things and
fail out go yeah I think I really do I
really want to become a marketing guy
and off I go and then we do this and
then I get this big campaign and we
launch it and we're trying to hit you
know 10,000 users you know within the
first 75 days or whatever it might be
and we only got to 2,000 and the project
I led failed I.E it did not meet the
criteria of its stated outcome objective
that is a failure and you failed to hit
that Target we need to own that when
you've got something at stake and it
doesn't happen it's costly and the
experience is called grief so I think in
the process of trying to get people to
to overcome unnecessary fear of failure
we start inadvertently judging people
who are in the cost of working through
the consequential there is a consequence
to something not happening as intended
so know when you're fail know when
you're set up with very little or
nothing at stake and no when you've got
something at stake and both plan and
process accordingly that's Thing One and
Thing Two I'll briefly I'm going do a
double here um all the time I go through
this conversation where somebody
something didn't work out and I'll and
I'll ask a whole room full of people
okay when something doesn't work when it
when it fails what's the first question
you ask yourself and 19 out of 20
people's first question is what did I do
wrong and that's one of those very very
powerful questions because it's a
terrible question that question believes
two things one is is if I had done
everything right it would have
worked now Dr Grace is you teach at the
lsse if I do everything right will it
work not necessarily not necessarily
because there a whole lot of things over
which you have no control whatsoever
that have nothing to do that you did it
right or wrong that's thing one so just
because it didn't work doesn't mean
anything was done wrong and number two
what did I do wrong meaning with hubris
I conclude I'm the center of the
universe and my single action was the
controlling outcome of the failure so a
much better question
when something doesn't work out which is
implied in what Grace just said I want
to double down on that is not what did I
do wrong or what did we screw up it's
what happened just the objective
question including things over which we
had no control whatsoever and so is this
just she said luck you know is it just a
circumstance from which I move on or is
there something to learn about and very
rarely you actually can go back to your
prior self you know 19 months ago when
you made that that commitment and say oh
yeah my 19 my my 20 my late 2021 person
self she screwed up she should have done
better she left it on that she mailed it
in she left it on the table she didn't
do homework that she could have done at
the time it is her fault she could have
done better that is extremely rarely the
case usually it's only my present self
would know something better than my
prior self did and present selves are
misjudging prior selves all the time
people cut it out we're all finite we're
learning on our way to go do objective
analysis and learn appropriately but
stop beating yourself up for stuff you
can't do Dave what is the generational
difference that you see if you're
talking to students they are in the
adulting phase of their life they're
kind of wow how could I find out about
all this stuff my goodness my goodness
I've got no experience but here I go
here I go grizzled old men like you Dave
know everything and have been through
every experience in life how did those
St changes happen well you actually
asked two questions there if you noticed
which metaphors you were using there's
the season of life and there's the
generation I'm in and they're different
uh the season of Life thing is real you
know uh first of all you don't even have
a neocortex until you're 27 or 28 a
little later in men oh what a surprise
um so the whole judging you know a lot
of people sort of like I really started
to get my act together in my 30s yeah
what do you what do you think I mean you
know you know you know we you know even
even people like the Buddha or Jesus
don't even really show up until they're
in their 30s um
but the um so the the season of Life
matters and there are different
experiences that are going on and you
know late life is different than early
life and then there's the generations so
a boomer mindset is different than gen
Zed and you know Millennial and those
things are culturally mattering and we
deal with both um I would say right now
um I mean the the fundamental
existential questions about who am I and
what is it mean to be a person and is
this working for me those questions
persist how I receive them a different
seasons of life is a little bit
different less different than you might
imagine the cultural differences are
really significant I mean so the Gen z
uh generation the first truly entirely
digitally enabled generation on the
planet Earth coming in a postco
environment with the worst student
anxiety and mental health in in in
history um what they're suffering is
very different than what Boomers did
when they were 20 um so I think you need
to be culturally sensitive but at the
end of the day we are all still people
and the big questions are there but they
change with time Grace can you take me
through as you say Dave period effects
and cohort effects so the notion of how
do those things change Through Time what
have you seen in the work you've
done so I think what has been really
interesting in the work that I've done
and also if you kind of look at the kind
of economic social science literature
more broadly is that as Dave said
there's these kind of season effects so
as people get older they change in their
attitudes and they change in their
beliefs so we can see that across
countries all over the world so people
will shift potentially from being saying
that they care care less about money to
caring more about money as as Financial
pressure comes on and then maybe a
little bit less as they get older we see
people's political views changing we see
people's kind of wants from work
changing and what they're willing to put
up within the culture I think what's
been really interesting about the co
pandemic and the um the the youngest
cohort of workers now so those basically
somewhere between kind of 20 and 28 so
spanning the kind of two generational um
generational labels is their preferences
seem to be much stickier than in the
past so I'm curious to see whether or
not they will continue to adapt as maybe
at a slower rate than before or whether
their preferences for particular types
of work life balance um you know the lie
down movement for me in China is really
interesting that people are saying well
we're not interested in in material
wealth anymore and we're willing we're
willing to sacrifice to get that we have
quiet quitting in the UK which is
similar to that but um not having as
much um as large imp on firms so I think
what has been interesting if we look
across cohorts now is for the first time
I think when it comes to kind of beliefs
and attitudes they're not changing that
where we might expect with people aging
but they're sticky so we have these kind
of sticky preferences Pro environments
sticky preferences for much more um work
life balances as as opposed to money and
yes I I I have no idea whether or not
that's going to um stay or whether it's
going to go over time this has been an
amazing time having this conversation
listening to you we talked about a
successful healthy life thank you so
much for so many clever ways to think
about who you are and your journey ahead
and how to be successful I would like
just to finish off from each of you in
turn to give me give our audience give
the people watching this just one tool
or one
exercise that they can practice maybe or
do every day to help them Center
themselves and have that great chance at
health happiness and success Grace could
I come to you first I think on the
exercise because as human beings we are
loss ofers and we tend to be drawn much
more to the losses that happen to us in
in our daily lives in our week as
opposed to the things that we actually
have so you know for example if a
colleague passes me today and they're
incredibly rude to me or they slight me
or they interrupt me in a meeting that's
going to weigh much more on me than a
positive interaction that I can have
with a colleague and if we're thinking
about happy lives I think you need to
consciously offset that through
practicing gratitude and you if you're
somebody who doesn't like to journal
this can be as simple as having an alarm
on your phone on at your 6 pm. commute
home or at 6 p.m. when you put down your
laptop and saying bring me five things
into my mind that I'm actually grateful
for and the way the human mind works is
if you don't do that it will continue to
be drawn to your losses and what's going
wrong which can make you quite miserable
but if you do you do it and if you give
your brain an instruction you're kind of
changing The Narrative of your story so
even on the crummiest days when things
don't go right maybe it's a prototype or
maybe it's something that's even bigger
for you just kind of centering yourself
and saying here give me five things that
are going really well in this day and
give me five more things that are going
well in general is a good way to live a
happy life Dave can I come to you but
Grace just to build on that very briefly
my executive coach said to me on the way
home Kamal think about the three things
that well not the 10 things that went
badly and I do stick to that yeah let me
double down on that a little bit and
actually give you sort of a granularity
to sort of zoom in on it you know one of
the things we bump into all the time is
one of the dysfunctions is there are a
lot of dualities out there which we
think are frankly you know dysfunctional
so I got work life balance and I I tend
to think as a as a duality you know if
work goes up life goes down if life goes
up work goes down so if you're in
marketing do I want market share or
profitability we set up all these binary
ways of thinking many of which are false
and one of the classics is the being
versus doing am I a human being or I'm a
human doing they treat me like a doing
at the at the job you know and we get
into this being doing flip-flop thing
and our reframe on that is a generative
cycle rather than a destructive
competition in a teeter totter which is
the being doing becoming so if you you
define a human being as a becoming we're
going to grow we're going to get better
if I'm going to get better I was worse
by the way I have to have been worse
yesterday in order to get better
tomorrow that's built in then my
question simply is how am I fueling my
becoming and that becoming I want to be
you know correlated to so I start with
who I really am I being and then I go
out the world and do stuff but I'm
trying to learn from what I'm doing and
experience things that are expressions
of my authentic self and that's a
becoming that my becoming progresses my
being upgrades and around we go in a
nice virtuous circle rather than a
vicious cycle and so the exercise would
be because there is no such you you
can't do the ultimate ever you can't say
let's go do
Beauty what do you mean well I can I can
make a beautiful cup of coffee but I
can't like just do Beauty you know let's
let's do justice I need to do justice so
I could do something
justly so philosophically this is called
the scandal of particularity turns out
the ultimate is only expressed in the
ridiculous so there's no such thing as I
was entirely myself today that doesn't
exist so you look back on that you do
that gratefulness thing but now what
you're doing you do a particular landens
and looking for when today did I
actually have an opportunity to express
or do or act out or collaborate in
something that mattered to me you know
so like being a collaborator really
mattered to me today so you know when I
when I asked that one more question on
our team meeting and then Grace showed
up with that idea which was not in her
her normal area of expertise she she
shared something about the way we write
and she's normally a processed person
you know and then I see I saw her smile
and so I helped real collaboration occur
today and that's who I want to be in the
world I feel great about that not just
oh was really cool when Grace shared
that thing but because that's an
expression of my value set so you get
good at Daily looking for those little
moments there are little moments
particular moments when an authentic
version of you got a chance to show up
in the world for a couple of minutes or
have an impact or a have a participation
that's when you're you're experiencing
authenticity or coherency and celebrate
that so the the suggest is find those
moments return to them in your mind Sav
because they go by in a heartbeat and
Savor them and that will animate the
real you and that will help catalyze
your becoming into your authentic self
incrementally slowly but surely over
time so look look for places you got to
show up in a meaningful way and
celebrate them Grace and Dave what a
lovely place to
end